sousse avec merci la parole et à
monsieur jean leonetti c'est le
président mes chers collègues d'abord je
voudrais très respectueusement rappeler
au gouvernement qu'il gouverne et qu'il
est dans la majorité et donc à force de
rappeler qu'à une primaire à droite qui
devrait être ne pas oublier qu'il a
d'amis la gauche d'une autre nature et
en même temps aussi se poser la question
auriez-vous déjà accepté votre défaite
ma question s'adresse à madame marisol
touraine ministre la santé un malaise
profond s'est installé peu à peu loin
des satisfactions que vous avez exprimé
auprès des professions médicales
d'abord malaise des médecins de ville
qui se sont vus imposer le tiers payant
alors qu'il croule déjà sous des charges
administratives malaise de
l'hospitalisation privée qui s'est vu
exclure totalement de la mission de
service public de santé
malaise des infirmières qui ont
interpellé l'opinion publique de manière
dramatique avec des suicides cet été et
qui ont rappelé la pénibilité de leur
mission enfin malaise des médecins des
hôpitaux qui ont été contraints à la
grève pour rappeler que 30% des postes
ne sont pas sont encore vacants ce qui
montre le peu d'attractivité de la
médecine hospitalière
quelle est la cause de ce malaise c'est
le manque de considération le manque de
confiance et le manque de dialogue qui
préside à toutes les décisions qui sont
prises
il ne faut pas comme vous le faites
depuis quatre ans toujours essayer
d'opposer non pas la droite contre la
gauche
mais les patients contre les médecins le
privé contre le public
la médecine libérale contre la médecine
hospitalière je sais qu'en payant de
fans banda les cadeaux vont se
multiplier
mais plus encore que des moyens
financiers la fédération hospitalière de
france vous réclame la considération
je cite la confiance et une politique
globale pour cela à mon avis il est déjà
trop tard
merci la parole et à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés et
monsieur le député léonetti
mais je pourrais répondre aussi de la
même façon à votre collègue gilles carez
qui que je remercie d'abord d'avoir
actes et le rétablissement des comptes
de la sécurité sociale
simplement comme une bonne nouvelle fait
trop de mal à avaler sur les bancs de
l'opposition
alors on nous explique c'est grâce aux
réformes qui ont été mises en place par
la droite mais à vous entendre bientôt
on va croire que c'est grâce au général
de gaulle que les comptes ont été
rétablies et la vérité et la vérité la
vérité c'est que c'est notre action et
vous savez la réforme de 2010 ou plus
que j'ai combattu
je n'ai jamais contesté qu'elle
apportait une contribution au
rétablissement parce que les femmes ces
messieurs les députés comme ce genre de
jeu ne suis pas sectaire
alors ou ne pas être sectaire je vous
conseille de reconnaître le travail qui
a été accompli qui a été mise en place
et qui nous permet de donner de la
confiance à notre système de santé et à
nos hôpitaux monsieur leonetti et le
plan en faveur de l'attractivité des
carrières hospitalières est un plan
majeur pour que les praticiens
hospitaliers puisse s'implanter dans des
hôpitaux qui ont besoin de bras dans des
spécialités qui manque de professionnels
et dans des territoires qui manque de
professionnels de la même manière que
des mesures ont été mises en place pour
que des médecins libéraux s'installent
dans des territoires ruraux ou urbains
en difficulté et ça n'est pas en les
opposant précisément monsieur le député
ça n'est pas en expliquant qu' il faut
fermer des hôpitaux de proximité
et que le service public hospitalier est
trop bien traités que l'on redonnera
pour